cuáles son los puntos más polémicos de
la reforma tributaria que el gobierno de
iván duque quería implementar bueno pero
que ya dio marcha atrás como decíamos
tres cosas fundamentales iba a tocar la
canasta familiar que en este momento es
un tema muy sensible aparte de la
pandemia lo segundo
el granca la carga tributaria y va para
la clase media de la clase trabajadora y
no hay digamos unos impuestos fuertes
sobre los grandes capitales y tercero
tampoco el sector bancario que ha sido
uno de los grandes beneficiados por la
pandemia y va a ser un gran
contribuyente
lo que más dolió en esto fue tocar la
canasta familiar porque realmente afecta
a la calidad de vida de los colombianos
ahora pese al anuncio no la retirada de
este polémico proyecto en algunos
sectores continúa el descontento social
en estas manifestaciones hay también
otros reclamos y descontentos verdad
cuál es el problema de fondo
hay muchos podríamos resumir que
ayudando que le convino la pandemia
porque antes de la pandemia de 2019 21
de noviembre ya habían unas marchas muy
fuertes en las calles por un descontento
frente a su política frente a la
política fiscal frente a la política el
tema de la implementación de los
acuerdos de paz frente a la política en
términos generales entonces hay muchos
debates ahorita viene uno muy delicado
que el país va a empezar estamos dejando
y estamos negociando el tema hasta ahora
de la reforma tributaria viene la
reforma a la salud un tema muy delicado
que también va a llevar a la gente a las
calles hay muchos problemas muy graves
en colombia la violencia y les doy este
dato el año pasado en colombia 76
masacres un país en guerra precisamente
bueno hablando de un país en guerra no y
demás a que sabemos ahora de la
violencia y organizaciones sociales que
están denunciando la muerte de decenas
de personas en manos de la policía
precisamente durante todas estas
jornadas de manifestación social
nuevamente el accionar de las fuerzas de
seguridad en la mira verdad
muy grave en los protocolos
internacionales lo que dicen es que se
tiene que hacer
el disparo en las manifestaciones de los
cuerpos antidisturbios tiene que ser
parabólico o dirigido hacia el piso pero
lo que encontramos aquí fue que los
disparos les están haciendo en directo a
los cuerpos de las personas hay personas
heridas que han perdido a sus ojos y hay
personas que han muerto y hay unas
investigaciones frente a esto pero la
actual de la policía sigue siendo
irregular frente a cómo se manejan los
protocolos internacionales en temas de
listo